those are the two things I hate the most
that guys use when when really what
happens in these situations specifically
when it comes to people who say got nice
guys finish last
mm-hmm you're really not that you're not
a nice guy nice guys don't have to say
that the nice guys yeah yeah yeah like
cuz you told me about a situation back
in the day where there was a guy who
really liked you
was it it was in Taiwan before you left
oh is it that one okay Oh which one it
was the guy that was in Taiwan and he
wrote the the letter for you oh no that
wasn't College that wasn't college he I
guess they're kind of similar if you
think about it because uh well he who he
was always in my friends well he put
himself in the friend zone like he was
always just a buddy and he never asked
me or anything like not that I was
interested in like I thought we were
totally friends and then towards the end
right after right before we graduated he
decided he's like hey you want to go
like it's not a door yeah I don't know
where and I was like oh yeah sure let's
have dinner you know but it was just
one-on-one I was like oh this is weird
and so just like that
yeah they were talking they're like oh
my gosh he's he's asking you I'm like I
didn't think like that that we're just
friends but then now that you guys say
like that like how am I supposed to
approach this and so it was like this
really fancy steak house by the way okay
like that good free meal okay I did get
a free meal and you know dressed up or
not but really awkward huh yeah it was
kind of awkward was it because he
couldn't really start a conversation or
what was awkward is because you knew
that he kind of wanted more yeah well I
don't know if it's more but I knew that
it was more than just the friend thing
because he didn't do that to all the
friends it was just me just do you and
you know before we left he wrote me a
very nice letter tight of course letters
always work homies you know saying make
sure you write that letter cuz after I
left the town though I was like I'm
never going back up and
I mean I he wrote a letter to you
laughter when you're happy left yeah
after we're done the whole [ __ ] point
of that guy I think it was just like a
closure maybe of like how he felt about
me but that said I didn't well I guess
what I'm asking is like when he wrote
you
was he expecting a response back like
hey I'm not leaving because after I read
this letter I have to stay here for you
I'm coming back for you and then you
know Korean drama music right when
you're about to leave you turn around
and he grabs your wrist and then the
cliffhanger yeah it's like foggy with
the glitter and zum-zum no no I just
text I remember like hey thanks for the
present yeah and that's it that's the
thing about that kid you scared to write
it's like he's very innocent and he's
like miss reading into a lot of these
situations like when a girl like for
example he is an amazing musician he
plays a guitar really really well so I
think with with the girl her name is
what was her name again Lauren Lauren
sigh right so Lauren shows interest and
she's excited about his music and he
kind of takes that as oh like this might
be a good segue for me to ask her out
any interest he thinks exactly any
interest which is true like when you see
a girl who's interested in something
that you're doing that's probably your
avenue to really establish whether
you're gonna be friends or you could
show interest problem with him is he
just stood there like a dumbass like
like he just stands there with his with
this with his mouth open just waiting
for something to happen and he's
creating these narratives in his head
you don't mean how do you know so well
because when I was younger I was just
like that I'm in it but that's what the
these are the qualities that we don't
like in people because if we see that in
ourselves right and so you were like
yeah music and no but that's more like
how I was when I was in high school like
14 15 maybe you know I mean like that
age so it's like I think for him because
he hasn't dated yet that he hasn't
experienced those these feelings right
but it's just like for what for example
he's not a bad-looking guy super
talented right very sweet very nice
and the one missing piece that he's
missing right now which I always talk
about is confidence his shoulders are
down he kinda had his tails beat his
tail between his legs yeah yeah if he
would just stand up straight yeah
talk to her look her in the eye but
instead when he talks to her he just
stares at the floor looks around and
it's not very attractive
he doesn't have swag if he had deal he
looks swag he's good all do the
basketball player of it exactly that
confidence relax on my couch you gave me
wet right yeah oh yeah the UH exactly so
in in the new season that guy has a lot
of confidence or even um even like that
goofy confidence that Pepe has right so
Pepe if you guys don't know is this if
you watch terrace house you could tell
him really into this [ __ ] is this
Italian immigrant he moved to Japan to
be a manga artist he's also confident -
but he's in the goofy like anyway right
cuz geeks can have confidence - Oh dolly
so Yusuke has none of that [ __ ] if he
had his music confidence maybe they're
just episode that you see where there's
very weird interaction between Lauren
and him or he's trying to ask her to go
to North Shore so was there on a wall so
he's trying to ask her to go to the
North Shore with him but then obviously
other people came along too because he
didn't really establish himself so the
reason why I get irritated about this
because this is really the interaction
that you see from guys that what really
happens but the story that they tell is
different not from Yusuke but other
people right so guys will be like oh man
like I'm just stuck I'm stuck in the
friend zone these nice guys finish last
it's like no it's not that nice guys
finish last
the girl was never interested in you in
the first place yeah you know what I'm
saying our guys are and in general our
guys like that I don't think all guys
are like that but I'm talking about a
specific type of guy that's very bitter
towards women because they are
inadequate it's not the girl's fault I
don't like it when guys blame girls for
not liking them a girl doesn't have to
[ __ ] like you they do not they do not
owe it to you to give themselves to you
because you're a nice guy you tell them
you tell them I hate that [ __ ] because
number one - it's it's like I'm not I'm
not mister you know what captain
save-a-ho mr. feminist or [ __ ] like that
but I don't like it when people
say that my you owe me your feelings
because I'm a good guy Mike how [ __ ]
dare you just be that's great you're a
nice guy you you're supposed to be a
nice guy but it's up to you to show
somebody kind of what you can offer them
in a relationship sense and on top of
that if you're a nice guy we won't be
nice to you exactly why why would we
treat you like crab when you're a nice
so we will give we will approach you
very nicely and they receive that I was
like oh we're moving on we're getting
something here it's like no is that
social awkwardness where they can't tell
what flirting is is right like because
because if they see them right and they
see that girl with another dude and they
kind of behave different it's like okay
that's attraction yeah I mean like
wouldn't when when you have interacted
with this girl she's very sweet she
smiles she's last she's having a good
time doesn't mean she's attracted to you
right it just means that you're a nice
guy is she's a nice girl and you guys
are having good interactions now if you
wanted to establish yourself and create
that relationship you you can't sit
there twiddling your thumbs expecting
things to happen you're not making a
move you're not asserting yourself
you're not letting that person know that
you want something more in a
relationship and by the time that time
passes like it's probably months maybe
sometimes even years for these guys and
then out of nowhere just like in your
case they go let's go on a date what the
[ __ ] what do you mean let's go on a date
yeah where did this come from how are
you supposed to take it like how did you
receive it I I mean we didn't see each
other after that he he lives up in
NorCal I live in SoCal and it was such a
I don't want to say it's a coward thing
because I don't know the guy right but
it's more like you know what was the
point I think for him is I might have
been a closer friend because he knew
that hey we're not gonna able to see
each other every day like we used to you
know it was kind of like Tara's house
because we had same classes every day so
we was each other everyday doing the
same activities and he knew that okay
this is gonna come to an end maybe he
had some feelings for me and he's like I
need to put a closure and do this so he
gave me a letter it was what was the
letter it was like wait I'm not reading
this correctly this is not a letter why
is it rhyming yeah
a sunflower and all right did it make
you feel sweet or did you they make you
want to throw up neither I was just kind
of like shocked shocked and laughing
because it was just so out of the blue
hmm
but I thought it was sweet but at the
same time I knew like or maybe he
already knew that how I fell about him
so I I was like I don't know how to
approach this like how do I responses I
have to say something so maybe it was
card of me I don't know because I just
texted him and said hey thank you for
the gift that's so sweet of you well I
mean what were you supposed to say you
see right yeah exactly
that's like I just don't like I'm not
saying that every person has to approach
a girl the same way right because some
guys have a more subtle approach I'm not
a very subtle person you know like when
we interact that was not subtle at all
no you weren't
that friends that friendzone [ __ ] don't
exist to me how I get rejected right or
you accept me either way well there was
no friend no that wasn't even an option
you told me you're like hey we're not
friends because you gave me the
crappiest hug ever I was like that's a
friend hug I keep the Lauren hug yeah
you get the Laurie side hug that's like
no I don't like I don't like that you
know